before I bring all my panelists here
just want to mention two things about
the mid-1990s when the internet was
first starting up to pop in a big way I
was optimistic and people would ask me
how big is this going to get and I would
try to envision it and I would say well
you know maybe hard million people might
be using this one day and even as I said
it I would think this is kind of crazy I
don't know if I really believe this and
and the lesson of that is that you
couldn't have been too optimistic about
what was going to happen with the
internet second point in 1996 a guy
named Bob Metcalfe was the inventor of
Ethernet was writing a lot of columns
talking about an impending internet
collapse and that collapse didn't really
happen and he had some egg on his face
when one hand on the other hand he wrote
a lot of columns about a lot of the
problems that turned out to be
persistent persistent challenges in the
Internet and that really is the focus of
our panel today because we're worried
now about this thing we have the
Internet
with his problems in security security
privacy reliability capacity and many
other things then with a Y that we
should be concerned about so fortunately
we have a terrific panel Q got I'll come
out here panelists please to help us
discuss this and you know do a reality
check about where we are on the Internet
so I'll introduce these fellows as they
come out first to my immediate left is a
poll Sagan and he's been with Akamai
Technologies since 1999 became at CEO in
2005 he had previously been with Time
Inc and he is a key person responsible
for things like New York 1 and
Roadrunner which I use every day and
he's also a board member one of my
favorite companies iRobot and to his
left
we have Pradeep Sindhu who is a founder
of juniper you've already met some
juniper people here he found that in
1996 and it's a way really the figured
out a way to dramatically improve the
router technology and he's really one of
the
thinkers of Internet infrastructure when
is it delighted to have Pradeep here and
then to my far left is uh Tim woo
Tim is a professor of law at Columbia
University he's currently on leave as a
senior adviser to the Federal Trade
Commission I I should note that he is
here not today as today not as a
government spokesperson but in his
professorial role and he's also the
author of a fantastic book called the
master switch which I recommend to all
of you so please welcome my panelists
now we're gonna talk a lot about the
challenges but before we get to that I
just want to spend a little minute on
the positive side I've been talking to
Pradeep a little you know and he shared
some thoughts with me which I thought
we're great I've just about the power of
networking pretty do you want to talk a
little bit about you know your
perceptions of why networking turns out
to be so important which I think gives
an indication why it's caught on and why
we're here really Steven I you know I
think I've had a long time to think
about why networks are important and and
what role they actually can play
it turns out that networks are curious
in one respect that they're very very
important to a lot of different things
but at the same time people tend to
discount them because networks are in a
sense abstract but what you see is that
almost in any system networks play an
integrating role which turns out to be
phenomenally important and as we
discussed yesterday the power of any
system is amplified tremendously by the
presence of a rich network we see this
with the internet we see this with a
human brain where the capabilities of
the human brain are possible only
because of some 10 to the 14 connections
between the neurons we see this at
essentially we see this inside computers
that the network inside a computer is
what gives it its capability so we we
I completely understand the power of
networks yet one day we will and when we
do I think we will look back and say
that you know networks occupy a really
central place in the development of
Technology right so so that's really
inspiring now let's get to the bad stuff
so even though the internet didn't
collapse in 1996 it has scaled
remarkably and and keep adding on more
and more you know in information more
more data moves on there and more people
are using it Paul why does it keep going
and are we worried now that it still
can't be overwhelmed it keeps going
because of this the power of networks
and the power of adding nodes as long as
they don't all go to a central location
right there's a big difference between
networks that are centrally controlled
and those that are distributed and the
Internet has had the benefit of being
extremely distributed and so you get
more and more power by the growth of the
nodes they don't just become an
overwhelming force it's why I porta Bob
Metcalfe been kicked already at least
once a day I saw him for dinner about a
week ago and he's still you know said I
ate my words were done with that huh but
he's not the only one obviously we're
not yes obviously we're not if you if
you know you go almost every two years
you can find a finished research or a
couple years later a German on and on a
couple more Americans you just keep
saying the Internet it's gonna collapse
and of course it hasn't we've seen
consistent growth in traffic
year-over-year for 15 or 20 years we're
seeing it move to new places that are
stressed and we need a lot of creativity
but I have no doubt that there that it
will happen because their business
models behind solving those problems so
the concerns to me or not that the
network is gonna collapse from traffic
there there are other issues that don't
have to do with technical capability
okay um well we'll get to them but first
saying there's the move to the mobile
Internet then put us in more of a
challenging situation you're nodding Tim
yeah well I was gonna talk about mobile
I wanted to add to the the sediment that
the Internet has stood up well a little
bit I think there's this persistent
tendency to underestimate the Internet
even though I mean we say in quietly
either say these either while
overly positive or wildly over negative
and I think there's been a lot of
underestimation of the internet
particularly in technical audiences
going back to about 1964 when you know
when you when you had the first designs
for packet networks and 80 you know had
a chance to invest in them and in fact
the the government was interest
investing and they just said you know
these decentralized networks are never
gonna work there's something very deeply
counterintuitive about the Internet's
design about this kind of unknown
packetized best effort run anything
network it sounds like it probably is
not gonna work you know it sort of seems
like if it were a bridge you wouldn't
want to walk on it would you want to
walk on the bridge it's made out of sort
of good solid bail protocols or the one
that's built sort of best effort I don't
know we try and do it everything gets
there and maybe it'll get there the
other side I think you wouldn't walk
across that bridge but it actually keeps
surprising people how well it works I
remember when I was last working Silicon
Valley well the first time in the late
90s early 2000s everyone was convinced
voice-over-ip
was never gonna work over the best
effort internet everyone was saying you
know we're gonna need the deploy the
next generation of whatever version of a
team you know very fancy equipment and
then the companies have bet against that
like Skype and advantage were two of
them
you know Skype half the time is better
than cell phone reception now there's
this consistent and no one thought video
would work unless we deployed a whole
bunch of stuff and a little bit you're
the project we're talking about so the
only end o projects type stuff but you
know YouTube then and actually your
company have shown that it's not perfect
but it kind of works and so I just want
to say there's been this consistent
almost cognitive problem of thinking the
internet is not going to work and then
it surprised people over and over well I
think the internet if you take your
metaphor is not a bridge okay a bridge
is a circuit switched yeah solution it's
you have to show up here and cross my
bridge in the internet says some days
you'll take the bridge and some days
there's a big ferryboat some days you're
gonna swim across and it finds a path
and it's a completely counterintuitive
but it's weird is an article of faith I
mean the think the fact this network
works is based on faith and a sort of a
lot of goodwill because it nobody owns a
thing I mean a tinker Bell prophecy
it's a weird it's a weird proposition I
I think we're used to it and we're in
this industry you know but it's a weird
proposition we're all gonna get together
no one's gonna own the thing it's a lot
more than an article of faith because
for networks at this scale the main
problem in the in building the Internet
is a problem of scale and you do not
build sand scalable systems in a
centralized way it just doesn't run it
does not work and one of the things
we've been able to do is for the last 20
years actually double the capacity of
the internet every year systematically
in fact for the last 10 years it's been
increasing at a rate of 2.2 X every year
so if we're so successful at this why
are we seeing some network providers
trying to push us to a role of metering
or Internet content there I mean that
that that sort of seems against the
grain of what we've been talking about
isn't it I think the challenge that
service providers have is that in some
cases they're there the demand on
traffic is increasing very very rapidly
but the revenues are not keeping up with
the investments in infrastructure and
that's the challenge that they face I'm
a little a little more cynical I think
there's a there's a appropriate market
driven naked grab for profit pool now
you used to work for Time Warner pool
yeah and and and profit seeking company
most of the time mine is as well I think
that's a good thing because it's driving
competition so you have people looking
and saying where are the profit pools
I'd like to have the biggest one
You certainly have stress in wireless
networks one of the irony is the
cellular networks are the new networks
and they were built wrong it turns out
right they were optimized for voice with
proprietary protocols and it turns out
people don't want to talk on these
devices that we want to push data and
we'd like to use IP and so they've got a
lot of work to do to get more scalable
to make them work but that doesn't
suggest to me that the internet will
collapse or that we just need to have
great sympathy and say they're the only
people with a problem we need to help
them out they'll evolve that Steven
there's one other aspect of the network
I think it's important to touch on
tcp/ip
is one of a handful of technologies
along with general-purpose
microprocessors and long-term persistent
random access storage
which we will find a way to increase its
power exponentially mm-hmm so this
interactive any-to-any networking is
fundamentally important to anything and
everything and and we will figure out a
way to to scale it exponentially
I'm this is like a faith-based argument
where you're having it's it is so many
many important institutions are articles
of faith I mean what why did let's take
the legal system something I know about
how does legal system where it doesn't
work as the policeman actually is gonna
catch you because most of the time
people mostly follow the laws and the
countries I don't they turn into anarchy
but to answer this particular question
about about why there's this so-called
desire to go towards metering this is my
own view not the government's view
definitely but III hold with that what
Paul says I think that ideally phone
companies would like to replicate the
conditions on the cell phone networks
where if your consumer you are forced to
guess how much you're gonna use and of
course you're always wrong right I mean
no one uses unless you happen using a
thousand minutes a month which I don't
think has anyone here ever done that
so either you guess you know you buy too
much you don't use it or you buy too
little and you get screwed with the fees
over overage fees and so either way you
lose and and it's it's actually a
practice that's illegal in other utility
markets for example the electric
companies aren't allowed to say guess
how many kilowatt hours you're gonna use
this month
you know what hours you're gonna use
this month it's a it's a continue some
practice actually because nobody knows
and then if you're wrong
you end up paying and so and consumers
aren't it puts all the risk on the
consumer so why wouldn't you want if
you're you know bail and it's a great
this is basically more elaborate version
of Apollo saying but yeah why wouldn't
you want that system has no relation to
reality mmm you know and a because you
know if you use that you don't use up
there's not some finite supply a
bandwidth a month that you run to the
end of and it's gone I mean you either
fill the pipe for a minute or you don't
as these guys know so that's not the
issue underlying really that what you're
saying there's the idea that you know we
have these duopoly Zaid ones wobbly and
on one hand and then you know just a
very few companies and you know
the mobile world there I'm wondering
whether this system is lack of
competition there is going to cap
innovation and you know just put us in
trouble in the longer term what do you
think I actually don't think so I think
there is sufficient competition in the
ecosystem that that the rate of
innovation we have what we're seeing is
that the rate of innovation is actually
accelerating it's not slowing down in
what area in the area of devices in the
area in the access part of the mobile
network in the core of the of the
network in the edge part of the network
no matter which part we look at we see
innovation so you called it dois Polly
Tim you know I I think that remember I
start open this conversation by saying
the internet had this uneasy berth in
the sense that it was always very
opposed to by the bail companies and I
think the relationship is still a little
uneasy put it that way I think they've
decided well maybe this thing is okay
and we have made some money off it but I
think there's still a easy relationship
and one if I would sail in the long term
threats to the Internet I think it's an
advance right now but if you want to
talk about a threat it's always been the
access points and and particularly I
think earlier this this decade or last
decade the idea of trying to have the
the access point providers decide who
are the winners and who are the losers I
think was very dangerous the internet I
think we sort of come past that and
that's I don't think people are talking
about that as much but the fast lane
slow lane stuff I think was dangerous to
the health the internet a little bit
further when we discussed with our key
customers it's clear now that they're
well past the point where they're
questioning whether IP is actually the
technology on which all services can be
built I we don't have a discussion of
any more people you know eight years ago
we used to have them today it's a
generally accepted fact that this
network is capable of supporting any
application that doesn't violate the
laws of physics right yeah I think the
thing that we have to watch out for is
in any portion of the innovation do
things get choked off to too few choices
and clearly access is one
would have a fundamental one but as we
look across it's been this flowering of
lots of innovation and rapid innovation
and often an unintended or unexpected
places that makes it work so there are
lots of reasons for example over-the-top
video is working today including fatter
pipes to most homes but one thing people
don't focus on is the Trojan horse
set-top box most people didn't say I
want a second set-top box in fact nobody
really wants that but 50 million people
connected gaming consoles for a
completely different reason and now
over-the-top long-form video works
because they have the internet on their
big screen called the TV and there you
had a market with lots of innovation and
more than three players and something
happened that we didn't even guess was
gonna happen and so I think the threat
is in any place does innovation come
down to too few innovators in a crisis a
place to worry the other aspect of the
internet that's worth pointing out it's
the ultimate platform I'm alone the
ultimate platform right and once you
create a platform like this there's room
for lots and lots and lots of people to
innovate the iPhone would not have
happened without an Internet existing
new over the top applications wouldn't
happen without this platform so there is
a lot of innovation going on yeah I
agree but I I'm gonna echo Paul's idea
that you know it's not like you create
the platform and it's sort of this you
know it's like an act of God or
something and it's you know it's a
man-made creature and it needs to be
changed and it can become and and I
think what Paul said earlier was right
that the strength at the very beginning
he said the strength of the Internet has
always been in its decentralization and
its diversity and those are mutable
characteristics that is they could
change and you pointed out you could
have a monopoly on access that could
change it if it was unregulated for
example completely unregulated and also
other parts of the network if you start
to lose diversity if you just have a
single company or one basically one
company deciding everything that goes in
one area there is some risk I think
yesterday health of the network so let's
look at the other side of the coin maybe
because of the openness of the Internet
in some other reasons as well I'm sure
we face a huge security problem here
lately we've seen these attacks
Anonymous global that show that the dark
side hackers can pretty much break
anything at will
Sonne or the CIA right and you know
there's problems with cyber thieves
hitting banks successfully and there's
you know god knows what the cyber
warriors for big countries are doing and
planning there
how tough is this problem here and and
and and what can we do the people who
are attacked basically you know that say
well you're next because you know even
though that they might have been
fingered for this vulnerability or that
vulnerability it's it seems that no one
is impervious to these attacks now and
the emperor has new clothes when it
comes to security so this problem is
fundamental and it will be there with us
forever so this issue of the trade-off
between sharing and security is very old
and anytime you build that the value of
the network is tied up with its openness
and its any-to-any nature and along with
good packets will go bad packets in an
ideal world you keep it completely open
and completely any-to-any
but the fact is that are bad actors and
so now you have to protect against those
it seems to be getting worse though I
mean at what point will we be forced it
or will we be forced to take measures to
clamp down on the openness now if no one
can be assured that their operations
will continue if the banks can't protect
our money I think that what we do
yeah the change of state Steven that's
happened is that in the past it used to
be people
hackers actually breaking into systems
just for bravado and now you have
organized in some cases countries and in
some cases organized groups that are
going after money and maybe information
and that's a change of state but I think
we will perpetually be in a state where
the defenses become more sophisticated
and the attackers become more
sophisticated and it's war right well
you're on the front lines Paul what were
you and it won't end because it's the
old line about you rob banks because
that's where money is and people have
figured that out so there's a go
this is a technology as a tool can be
used for good or bad mostly good we see
some bad there are lots of technologies
that we now wake up every day with and
live with for good or bad but we don't
lose endless sleep so nuclear
power is one and both for good and bad
and you know a whole generation woke up
every day for a long time thinking the
world might end and we got to a point
where fair stability we're gonna the
same thing for sure on the internet and
the security model will change I think
what's happened is the attackers the bad
guys have moved quicker because they saw
a chance to profit with their business
model completely nefarious and the
security model changing we're seeing
that today the traditional security
model was was you know go into your home
and build a moat and secure it it's
really not the best place to secure your
home if they're bad guys are at the back
door already you're in trouble the
models are now moving too broadly
distributed security so we saw you may
remember the fourth of July attacks two
years ago that took down a number of US
federal sites they didn't take down all
of them the traffic actually all came
from one country in Asia which country
without B it emanated from machines in
South Korea it wasn't controlled from
there and for certain sites in fact the
ones that we protected federal
government sites that didn't go down all
the traffic was stopped there never left
the frontier if you will so there are
new security models that are evolving
that can handle some of the new kinds of
threats there is no silver bullet I
absolutely agree with pretty we're not
gonna end it but we're just kind of a
continuing arms race and people will
learn how to secure things I do think on
the state level we've moved from this
fear of nuclear war which hasn't gone
away to the fear of of a cyber war and
that is of a obviously of a scale that
goes beyond business to deal with and
we've seen that in a couple of cases
already I'll say one thing I'll take a
cyber war over nuclear war if that's
where we're going I'm pretty happy
frankly I mean I can be bad although it
sort of depends how it's launched if it
drives planes out of the sky
we might not feel down Indian Point it
gets to be academic to the people who ya
know I didn't want to belittle it but I
mean the other war was a lot worse a lot
worse yeah I think I think you know
another thing which is I think we're
headed towards this which is that we
should not give any safe haven to people
who want to do damage
and here if we can have a set of laws
that are enforced uniformly that would
be of great great yeah well that's a
great point there is no body to do that
so for example in the case of the July
4th attacks we knew where the attacks
came from it was almost unenforceable
you couldn't go get them and by the time
you might get even therefore friendly
allies to do it the bad guys are gone so
will we be blacklisting domains or
countries in order to I think we have to
use something like that because
otherwise these these actions will
continue actually it's one of the areas
where I think and I will speak as a
member of the federal government where
it may be law would be useful you know I
mean ultimately no matter how much of a
hacker you are you ultimately have a
body and a body can be I mean a physical
body and you can be put in prison and
that that is sort of the ultimate
deterrent and and I I think some of it
has to do with a certain sense I think
in law enforcement there's a little less
priority given to these things there's
some but not the same I mean people are
used to sort of going after bank robbers
and drug dealers and hackers sort of
seem to like talk about them but so it
seems like a joke and you know they you
know I don't think it has the same kind
of seriousness I know it's in the
newspapers but I think in law
enforcement culture I don't think there
is quite there's a little bit I mean
there is it just but not the same level
of resources that there could be for
combating this stuff well maybe it is
one of the things that is a problem of
government I know some some laws and
regulations that are being talked about
will be in one hand to build
surveillance into the design of the
internet another would be to build
copyright protections in deeply you know
within the internet there how does the
copyright protection preventive Swami or
basically that have laws to basically
mandate you know the systems and you
know makes you build it on the ISP level
yeah you know some things to protect
copyright there any enthusiasm for that
some something that'll really help
actually is strong authentication before
you get on the network I think that that
definitely will help so where you can
actually rely on the fact that if
packets are coming from its packets say
they're coming from here they're
actually are coming from so you're you
suggesting to move away from the
anonymous
in Internet where we almost need a
equivalent of a cyber driver's license
through well we actually we're not
operating in an honest Internet anyway
but but I think having a more reliable
set of pieces of information where you
can rely on this person is the person
that he or she says she is and there's a
difference between anonymous and
authenticated because even in an
anonymous environment in fact it might
be more important to say I know that
that handle is really the same person
they could be authenticated and still
remain anonymous at some level and then
you could have rules in different
communities for whether you have to be
anonymous use your real name but at
least know it's the same person behind
which is not communicating and you're
getting closer to cures that are worse
the disease though that's what that's
what I mean I don't know it so takes
years years themselves use the right
tool which the hell the internet for if
I shouldn't use a sledgehammer if we
need just a little a little but here's
the thing I think you can have degrees
of anonymity and the more anonymous you
want to be the fewer things you'll be
able to do and that's a fair trade-off I
say but there is this underlying danger
that you know security people react or
people do not react calmly to security
threats obviously and so there's an
obvious tendency to go too far and sort
of shut down some of what is originally
good about the internet which you know
cost us in terms of economic growth and
stagnation I mean everyone if every site
was like a bank site you know if you to
get onto Google or Facebook you had to
identify your cat and three of your last
pets and Mike your grandmother's sister
I mean that would make it unusable yeah
you don't you don't want somebody
anonymous to log into your bank account
for example but you know what is the
role of government yeah yeah you you you
mentioned you open this up Tim some
people feel hey the internet leave us
alone
you know we'll do fine without any
government intervention any law that
that comes off there's some group that
adopts a name you know that protect our
internet you know
the laws but it's a net neutrality or
something else there
what is the role how activists should
the government be right in protecting
were regulating even the Internet
well I mean it's a big topic and it's
you know a bigger topic as political
theory itself like what what should
government ever do I am strong the
tradition in this area is for government
and I mean 100-year tradition is for
government to be extremely activist in
in communications it basically
guaranteed a telephone monopoly for most
this century it helped out ABC NBC CBS
made them the official networks you know
so there's a strong history of heavy
government and I'm generally opposed to
that and I think we've come a long way
from the the days where government would
decide what the media future was because
it was too important for the market on
the other hand I do think there are
particular public values in
communications I don't I think that news
and communications are slightly
different than potatoes or neckties or
other markets so they have sometimes
public facing considerations that that
might warrant more oversight so
basically what I think government's role
is is to particularly have oversight
over the problem of monopolization in
this area over the problem of excessive
private power which is cutting down on
innovation and economic growth that's my
bottom line I think the second one is
the rule of law right I said that
earlier is to enforce basic criminal
laws against well there is no strain
which says then it is absurd to pursue
monopolization on the internet things
change so quickly that you know the
natural forces the innovators dilemma
will overturn the company that dominates
at one moment i don't think any natural
forces were gonna overturn microsoft
circa 1996 personally and i and i think
that was an important action by the
federal government to prevent the use of
the Explorer browser then 2001 about 95
percent of the market from from being
used in ways that would have had a big
impact on innovation in the last
so I'm not a big interventionist but I
do think in monopolies how long they
last is a really interesting question
and I don't I mean yeah sometimes they
go away look at companies like lol
stilts kind of around but they were
really big and went down but sometimes
like in last decades you know decades
and decades and have a big effect on the
market now I think he's hit the the
right - and there are some cases where
you want a monopoly in the
circuit-switched
world we wanted one because it was much
more efficient so it needed to be
regulated today that's very different in
a packet switch environment the the
concerns of scarcity have moved to
another place so are the kinds of things
we're talking about going to be bigger
concerns or maybe even retardants - are
entering the cloud era what what impact
does our movement to the cloud which
pretty much everyone thinks is
inevitable going to do to these issues
that we've been talking about and after
we discuss the cloud for a couple
minutes I want you to start thinking
your questions and if you're on Twitter
and you're following it hash mark next
work so the cloud is certainly an area
where I think government is tempted to
dabble and it's very early and that's a
little bit scary right the question for
examples the question of weirdest data
reside and who's responsible for that
and who can go get it if the cloud sort
of presumes that everything is
virtualized so you don't know where your
data is governments are about physical
regulation you know I know my borders
and I want to regulate them suddenly if
the data doesn't really exist in borders
if a government says it has to or turns
out that data sitting in some country
the country says I'm gonna go get that
they have a different privacy policy to
a corporation or a user that's a scary
potentially large dilemma and I think
countries naturally gravitate towards
wanting to secure things in a bordered
physical way and there's a lot of
discussion around regulating of cloud
for example which is pretty early on to
try to write those and rules I'm
actually very nervous about governments
regulating architectures which just in
their infancy in fact one of the
challenges of cloud is that security
becomes a lot more important now that
you don't have physical control of your
data as Paul mentioned the data may be
sitting
far away and perhaps in more than one
place ensuring its physical security is
actually very important and a difficult
problem yeah I don't know I mean I don't
know I think I agree with the sentiment
of government shouldn't regulate early
stage industries and and as I said I
think the most appropriate role is for
the government to wait and be nervous
about massive concentrations of power
Standard Oil like situations you know
where the market is stagnated choked up
by a single company who has is shows no
sign of his appearing now you never know
for sure so the cloud I mean regulation
the cloud is is mostly premature I I
think that in the abstract no one wants
to regulate these things on the other
hand when you get to a specific issue
they might for example I think that many
Americans and people around the world do
want some oversight of the privacy
practices of the main information
collectors you know they just take one
example google buzz was something a lot
of people were not that's a cloud event
and you know they was a fairly clear
violation of federal privacy law and I
think most people think that when we
click there's one thing to say regulate
the cloud there's another thing to say
well because it's called a cloud thing
if you violate a very clearly
established privacy law that you're
exempt from the law I don't think that
makes any sense and so I think most
Americans do want there to be oversight
at least to the extent of very clear
violations of privacy laws or deceptive
practices in particular you know you
don't tell people what you're doing with
their information you you collect it
without them telling it then you use it
in ways you haven't told them that I
think most no one cloud or no cloud no
one wants that okay great well let's
open it up to questions here the
audience a chance to throw something at
our panelists here do we have a there's
one question okay wait for the
microphones who would reach you please
but Kevin Kelley wired my question is
about the global implications in terms
of the issue of global regulation versus
national regulation so we see a cloud
coming we see the fact that this is a
global machine we have least in this
country a resistance to the idea of
global government and all the kinds of
scary things that that entails so is
there any appetite for having some kind
of real reach so that the bad guys in
another country if they move the data or
we have some understanding that moving
something from here there doesn't really
change things so what do you think about
that is this is this something that is a
first step towards it or is this another
utopian well I think it is inevitable
because the Internet is the most complex
and in fact the first truly global
machine as you mentioned and it knows no
boundaries and therefore the laws
governing it can't be
only local yeah I have to be global yeah
I don't the path of the law I don't
think is follows logic in the way it
ought to yes the Internet is is global
but unfortunate
there's a lot of when you really boil it
down I mean basically we still have
national governments the United Nations
is not a really a global government so
we have national governments and they
are staffed by people and they have
their reactions I think that the way it
is I don't I'm not gonna say how it
should be I'm gonna say how it is I
guess which is to say there are a few
countries that are taking the lead in
regulating some some of the or not
regulating certain internet issues
and the more internationally or
domestically so there's a series of
countries that have felt variant that
they want to regulate the internet
extreme
heavily domestically in a big example of
course of China which wants to censor
the internet and then there's countries
like the United States who have a very
different set of priorities which are
frankly anti-regulatory we want other
countries not to regulate the internet
because it's bad we don't think it's
right and also it's bad for American
business and we think also sort of
violet of free speech so you end up with
these different sort of legal regimes
and ideologies fighting off against each
other in fact what you have in some ways
is a replica in the internet space these
days of some of the Cold War dynamics
where we think it should be one way and
other countries think it should be other
ways it's not as intense and there's no
nuclear weapons but there's no
presentation of this yeah there's a
balkanization and an attention between
different nations as to how the internet
should be and the United States is still
basically home base for tcp/ip internet
should mostly be free kind of thinking
but it's not there's sort of Europe has
a much more and more intrusive and then
you finally have China and some other
countries in Asia which are the most so
there's there's it's coming like that
and I doubt that they'll be sort of
certain serious treaties or there's a
little bit but no like but here's one
thing there's hope for being optimistic
because the value of the internet gets
maximized when there's minimum
balkanization and hopefully you know the
Chinese government will realize that in
fact for their society to be as
innovative as possible requires an open
Internet yeah but what you run into is
the fact that countries traditionally
see Communications as a state function
you know I mean it's the problem you
know the first thing that the rebels do
is take over the radio station people
most countries see the news the media as
for as something that government does
and controls and that Americans do not
see things that way what we have PDFs
but besides that no we have them in the
tradition here so these traditions run
into each other and there are really
fundamental differences they're not just
like they're more fundamental even than
difference between the Bell company and
Internet people like these are deep
running ideas as to what sure keep you
know how a nation should communicate and
so I don't think you can sort of solve
them very easily and I follow up
question from Twitter it who moderates
the global network I don't know if there
is a who moderate slip again Network oh
there isn't yeah there isn't which which
makes it such a fascinating problem
which gives the power to the Internet
right and the power to innovate and come
up with new models in fact I think
because no one does sit in that central
position it's a much more dynamic the
United States needs to be the champion
of an open Internet because all the
countries love to hear that right well
the United Sates is I don't mean I'll
speak for the government for a second
again that there's a fellow there there
at the State Department and Hillary
Clinton to her credit has established an
entire unit whose idea is to sort of
promote the idea of an open Internet the
world and I think they're doing a
terrific job there's there's a series of
people whose ideas it but there is
resistance again because people want to
control things there are areas where
countries roughly agree like in privacy
we sort of roughly the Europeans are
stronger about it but there's some
agreement so there's cooperation but
there's some areas there's very deep
disagreement I'll say one last thing
there's this dangerous problem however
where sometimes the most restrictive
state ends up getting its say so for
example if Europe has the most
restrictive privacy laws those can
become the world's laws for
multinationals in the sense that you
know if let's say Facebook obeys Europe
and Facebook doesn't want to recode for
America then in the same way California
sets emission standards for the whole
United States Europe can often end up
setting the standards for the whole
whole world
very important for us to be in the
debate as a country yeah and not allow
it to go there rapidly right yes well
we'll be discussing this a little more
this afternoon when Jared Cohen who
worked with Secretary Clinton is going
to be speaking up there there's no
there's one question the backend you can
ask it really quickly we could get this
in before we break thanks to you
Jack Henry on the one hand the Internet
is made of massive amount of progress
exponential growth great but there are
certain parts of the infrastructure of
our society that have been very
resistant to that specifically the smart
grid has been this lot of hype for the
past five years
millions of articles I'm sure you've
been wired and The Economist about smart
grid it's coming tomorrow it's coming
yesterday we're gonna wire up every home
with a smart meter we're gonna have time
of day pricing coming via the internet
we're gonna drive appliances to turn on
at night turn off through the day and
yet four five six years all height very
little reality why do you blame it just
on the utilities you guys want to do it
and they're resisting or is there a
deeper reason I think the deeper reason
is that when you look at the smart grid
most of the problem is actually at the
edge of the network and the edge of the
network or the access part of network is
actually a very difficult problem
because you need the devices to be very
very low cost and yet very reliable and
those two things don't really go well
with each other so I agree that there's
been a lot of hype there in fact one of
the things that the utilities are doing
is trying to promote completely
different set of standards than the
existing standards for networks and this
is lunacy if you really want low cost
implementations there's another cog
there's a cognitive problem where people
consistently underestimate the cost of
the last mile yeah over and over and
over against happen for history over
inside there's a full graveyard full of
companies that have done that including
the guys who are clowning through the
sewers with little robots with fiber
optics the you know the last mile is a
graveyard for a huge number of companies
and I think it has also taken the smart
grid ideas with it yes okay great well
what finally a note of pessimism thank
you but I want to thank our panelists
here for keeping the faith please give
them a warm hand